we had emotional overload
it's a lot to stay tuned uh lying lie
detector
they're not always accurate and bennett
leaves
really goodbye but not for long and then
he comes back and appears kind of insane
hello tasha
hi this is you're the bachelorette
season 16 episode 9 recap grab your
glasses
it's time for roses and rose hi
everybody it's me lauren zema and
bennett is gone
is this really goodbye but then he
returns
hi can we speak for a minute and
everyone is staring
and also crying what an episode
that was interesting it was a curveball
did not see that coming
oh babes i'm coming at you with a dark
red wine and a dark
pant because things are getting dark
not dark like scary dark like sad but we
love an effect
well things got dark and we got so much
to get to so let's
get to it so we begin at the beginning
of the end of bennett but then he does
begin to come back in the end but anyway
we pick up where we left off last week
was all
what's in the box what's in the box this
week that didn't matter we didn't really
address the box any further
but tasha did address her feelings for
bennett
and noah and tasha tells bennett that he
makes her feel heard
but he also says condescending things
you have made me feel
hurt this entire time but it worries me
you are condescending
the way that you talk to people and
questions her intentions
you questioned my intentions auntie
tells noah
i'm still getting to know you and i'm
not sure that you're ready for marriage
i have enjoyed getting to know you the
thing is i'm also worried that you're
not ready for marriage at the end of
this
interesting i am it was okay
kind of a big thing to say okay
but between the two she casts off our
superman boo
goodbye bennett unfortunately i can't
give you this rose
what did you think of this decision i
sort of felt like
she could have sent him both home in
that moment i don't think she has
physical chemistry with bennett and i
don't think she has a strong enough
emotional connection to noah but let me
know in the comments below
either way when she sent bennett home
her face was so
stoic can i walk you out please
no emotion i'm shocked
damn tasha
okay stoic lauren not dead okay
bennett's face was
also a little blank i kind of felt like
he was in shock that he didn't think he
was going to go home
he even says is this really goodbye
is this really goodbye
he can't believe it can you no
don't be smiling but more solemn
stoic savagery from tasha she tells noah
oh no
no noah this doesn't mean you get a rose
pal
i'm not gonna give you this rose right
now either
i truly don't know how i feel right now
noah's gonna have to go out to the
cocktail party
so tasha returns to the rest of the men
and she says
bennett is no longer with us as you all
may have noticed
bennett is no longer with us again no
emotion wow
the drama is over for now and i just
want to be done with it all
don't worry we'll get to the emotion
later so let's just have a good night
can we
of course okay guys and it's the
cocktail party so we are gonna have
a little fun don't drink for every time
someone gave a gift
riley gives tasha a one week anniversary
cake got a little something for you here
little happy anniversary cake
i love cake do you like cake what's your
favorite type of cake i love cake and i
do love funfetti cake i might argue that
that's my favorite cake however you
cannot go wrong with a glass of
chocolate cake i mean if i'm gonna have
dessert i usually like it to be
chocolate it's not that i don't like
fruit i think the fruit's wonderful it's
just that fruit can also be breakfast
and if i want dessert i want dessert you
know like i want my full
sugar intake and chocolate just feels so
decadent and delicious and like such a
scape i love a german chocolate cake i
love a classic chocolate chocolate cake
i'm from chicago and portillo's if
you've ever been there as the most
amazing chocolate cake and
i could just talk about cake for so long
have you ever had like an oreo cake
where oreos are incorporated somehow ooh
red velvet cake but like not cream
cheese frosting i don't love cream
cheese frosting
[Music]
i really could keep talking about cake
what's your favorite dessert i come
bearing gifts
what is that zach gave tasha one of
their quasi wedding photos framed as a
gift
oh do you love it i like that
i love a framed photo and i mean you
have to be so selective about your
framed photos these days because we all
take so many photos on our iphones and
honestly i think
we take too many photos we need to be
living in the moment more it's like put
away the phone and just be here be
present
but so then we have to be even more
careful with choosing what photos are
going to make the frame you know what
will you take the time to print out to
go pick up to frame and put in your home
on display forever and exactly tissue
that photo so i thought it was
meaningful and emotional
wasn't cake though
[Music]
and ben gave tasha several of his
signature kisses
and no one was complaining about that
we're really bad at that
what we're so bad at that now it's time
for the rose ceremony
and oh oh oh
i just want to give a quick shout out to
ivan because
as he was squinting he said he couldn't
see how many roses there were and could
anyone tell him
the number i can't see that far how many
is there five
and i could just relate i have a
horrible vision
so cheers to ivan you know what makes
everything look good
if you've been drinking wine
brendan so tasha gives out the roses
and spencer is gone we'd pretty much
forgotten about him after his crazy
night one entrance which one of you guys
scared away claire
dan i have to say that i was on nick
files podcast where i'm going to call
him out right now nick pile said he
thought spencer would be in the top
spencer is uh tisha's kryptonite and i
said no he won't he's just a quick flash
in the pan and anyway
bye spencer and sorry nick can't wait
for us to see who's right on this one
who's on the right side of spencer
history
and ed is gone and we want to pour one
out
not really because we don't waste our
wine but to ed because ed was fun to
watch and he seemed
nice thank you so much i appreciate you
and damar is gone and he always gave us
positive vibes and good
songs she stole my breath
what did you think of the mantaisha sent
home were you surprised
did it seem right let me know in the
comments below
and then there were seven so there are
seven men left and we are told next week
is hometowns
next week is hometown week gosh it just
feels like it came up on us real fast
didn't it and i suppose that was because
we had a totally different bachelorette
at the start of the season and we saw
her get engaged and tasha really got
half of a kind of extra long season so
anyway here we are
let's do a helpful cliff's notes make
sure we're all on the same page recap
don't drink for every guy who's left
[Music]
whoa but then things take a turn zach
is crying everything gets real
you guys this has felt like a very
emotional season
with tasha and these guys we've seen
them all open up so much
share and reveal intense stories from
their past in every episode but that was
usually like on a date it's the middle
of the day
the date card just got delivered and
zach's breaking down
it's a lot stay tuned i think he's
crying because he
is happy with tasha and he wants his
parents to see that happiness and so
hometown's made him think of that we're
crying after getting a date card what is
happening to these men
i'm not judging crying it's just we
can't be breaking down
all the time is tasha that amazing that
she just has them in a constant state of
emotional
wreckage yes maybe that's it yes she is
awesome
ben falling in love is full of surprises
oh but zach didn't get the one-on-one he
wanted hun
it's ben and tasha and they're going on
a scavenger hunt
you guys are gonna have to work together
on solving my little
clues and riddles so don't drink for
every scooter
don't hate me for doing this don't drink
for every tennis ball
[Laughter]
side note ben got pantsless again you
are not
it's really becoming his thing and
because here we are
don't drink for every pinata
that's one way to all right before we
start let's just do it cheers
and now ben and dasha are at dinner i
don't know if we can actually be
something
if he doesn't open up to me ben did
reveal more
he shared that he had attempted suicide
in the past i had two failed suicide
attempts
in 2018 2019. i cannot
raise my glass enough to ben ben thank
you for opening up
on national television about things that
i can't imagine are in any way shape or
form
easy to talk about i see you when i hear
you
and that's all i've been wanting and we
love ben
right i see you ben stands out there and
ben gets a rose i want to know if you'd
accept this rose
ben is going to hometowns everybody side
note how are they going to do hometowns
when we're trapped at the la quinta
i mean we're definitely not going to
someone's hometown
whatever home is where the wine is the
heart is
and whoa whoa whoa
emotional overload
tasia says she loves ben
i truly love that
did you guys see that coming i didn't
see that coming
but we've got to move forward we've got
to move on
it's time for the group date
and you know i have questions the group
date seemed to be some kind of
for lack of a better word rudimentary
lie
detector test that is a polygraph test
and we are going to be testing you all
today
i hope i'm using air quotes properly
when people do this
i don't really know what that means what
did you think
of the lie detector test it seemed to be
a laptop
with a squiggly line and some light
bulbs
i mean the light bulbs didn't even make
sense to me because we had like a green
a yellow and a red i was like we're not
in a traffic light
that didn't seem right to me and jojo
fletcher as much as i love her
was administering it are you truly
falling in love
don't you have to be like licensed in
some way someone with an authority on
this subject
please let me know in the comments below
about the efficacy
and the circumstances that must surround
a proper lie detector test you know
honestly i wish we just played like that
old sleepover game two truths and a lie
should we play it now okay okay okay i'm
gonna give you guys two truths and a lie
and the answer will be at the end
of the video if you don't know how to
play this game i'm gonna say three
things and you have to figure out which
one
is the lie of the three things i'm
allergic
to face masks i was once
on a volleyball team
i have three siblings
what do you think the lie is let me know
in the comments below and also it will
be
at the end of the video
but we didn't do that we're doing the
lie detector chess thing so
zack sits down can you see yourself
falling in love with tasha
and zach is emotionally invested it
might have already happened
zach is ready yes
tasia was staring stoically earlier zach
is staring intently now
he's looking right at tasha he's ready
to take the
test and so zach admits
he's cheated have you ever cheated on
someone
yes
and tasha does not like this she has
said that her ex-husband cheated on her
and tasha states that she subscribes to
the saying
once a cheater always a cheater i feel
like the saying is true wants a cheater
always a cheater do you
agree i do not i think that people cheat
at different points in their lives for
different reasons and
that while some people are perpetual
cheaters not all
what do you think let me know in the
comments below you might be used to this
you ever do this with your clients
oh but a voice of reason is here a
saving grace
a legal mind riley the lawyer sits down
for the
test
i'm sorry and riley says that he refuses
to let his clients take lie detector
tests because they are often
not accurate i refuse to let them
they're not always accurate
riley fails on some things he is asked
his name
and apparently riley is lying
how what is your name devin
reilly christian
whatever it was all questionable onto
the nighttime portion
antaisha as always is looking gorgeous
though i could not figure out why she
was wearing this ball gown
isn't it hot in the desert isn't this
just a group date
why are we dressed like we're ready for
a princess wedding whatever i don't care
she's our princess queen and i love her
i always say it's better to be
overdressed than underdressed
yes i've cheated in my past
oh but she is over what zack said she
confronts zach about the cheating
cheating does not does not
sit well with me that's nothing i will
tolerate and zach reveals the cheating
was in the sixth grade
yes this was a little anticlimactic
wasn't it uh
zach says he cheated on his first
girlfriend
at the bolo rama with a makeout session
in like the sixth grade i later met up
with that girl
at a bowling alley a bowl-a-rama and i
french-kissed her while i was still
dating emmy
it was like my first girlfriend in sixth
grade
and that's my cheating story
so that's what i'm saying you guys it's
not once a cheater always a cheater
oh but then emotional overload
tasha is falling in love with zach
i wanted to reach over and grab some
following
[Music]
did you see that coming
i don't really know what that means now
riley is crying
[Music]
emotional overload
you okay well good let's have a seat yes
riley is in tears over sharing a story
with tasha about his family and it seems
it stems from issues with his father
and he did legally change his name
because of his father i decided you know
i could be a better man i could be an
honorable man if i worked hard at it
but the only way to do that was to start
over you know i got a legal name change
people change their names all the time
and that is why he failed the
rudimentary lie detector test
i mean even tasha says these talks are
too emotional
so much so that she doesn't know who to
give a rose
to i don't want to just give out a rose
just to give out a rose
i feel like everything meant so much
tonight
but i think i just need a little bit
more time as to who to give this to
i agree i don't know what to think
anymore we're lost in the
emotion but in a glass case of emotion
i'll be honest you guys these last few
episodes have been
heavy you're just feeling like a lot
altogether is that just me
what do you think let me know in the
comments below oh but this show is the
gift that keeps on giving
a little lighthearted escapist drama
is here in the form of
bannon hello tasha
hi yes he was only sent away
a mere two hours of tv time ago
hi and bennett has showed up don't you
know
he has shown up on tasha's doorstep in
the cover of night
and i have to say he is using the
creepiest voice i've heard in a while
great to see you so nice to see you what
was that he's like great to see you
great to see you so nice to see you
so nice to see you you look beautiful
it smells fresh in here
it smells fresh in here fresh like what
fresh blood
and did anyone else notice the whole
time
he wasn't blinking don't drink for the
whole time
bennett didn't blink
did i blank i don't know i don't know my
eyeballs
i'm so legally blind i have the contacts
it's actually easier to keep your eyes
open
suticia says let's talk and she takes
him
into her villa and i loved how she was
like oh sorry
i didn't even clean up well i didn't
really clean up
i was like tasha girl it looks perfect
in there there's not a pillow out of
place
she even like tried to make it look like
she was cleaning up she was like
have a seat sorry it's okay you're
perfect you're perfect
he says that this has all been a
whirlwind
it's been a little bit of a whirlwind uh
to say the least
whirlwind bit of a whirlwind world wind
the whirlwind world wind
the whirlwind
bennett's return to tell tasha that he
was thinking all of these things that he
wanted to share that he hadn't been able
to
and i was thinking of all these things
that i hadn't been able to share with
you
you know sometimes you don't realize
things until they're gone
and i'm like please not another
heartbreaking personal story emotional
overload i can't take anymore
oh but it's not it's not what i thought
bennett tells her he loves her and i
realize in that moment that i love you
what what
what what
what did you all think of this yes
bennett tells tasha
that he loves her and i realized in that
moment that i loved you
and to be honest i was just thinking
this was part of bennett
losing his way a little bit and i felt
it was all embodied in his hair
being out of place bennett tells tasha
and i quote
you have every ounce of my heart i don't
use that word lightly
you have every ounce in my heart right
here i don't use that word lightly
what word whirlwind
then it then says he will do anything in
the whole world for another chance
love nothing more than to you know stay
for you and i'll do absolutely anything
in the whole world
like what oh he says he is
dead serious about her
because i'm dead serious about you
antaisha
reveals to bennett that she actually
wasn't planning on sending him home
the night that she did i'm not gonna lie
to you i was not planning on
saying goodbye to you that night and
remember she
failed the rudimentary lie detector test
when it asked her if she had any regrets
about sending anyone home
do you regret sending anyone home no
lie detector tests are 100 accurate
completely and utterly reliable
and should be used as a fully
functioning part of
your regular and everyday lives
but back to bennett bennett tells tasha
he has never had emotions like this
about a girl
i haven't had emotions like this ever
over a girl
which is interesting because he was
engaged but taysha rejects bennett's
kiss
no nice try which is interesting because
i think that says it all about how she
just feels about bennett
though she does say she has always
wanted a guy to
and i quote show up for her like that
i've always said i wanted a guy to show
up for me like that
and and i was wondering tasha what do
you mean
in the dark hi on your doorstep
[Music]
uninvited no
deja doesn't know what to do
i am so confused but luckily she has red
wine which helps
what did you guys think she should do
should she allow
bennett back into the fold oh but we see
that she does yes because we get a
teaser for the next
two yes next week we have two episodes
and bennett is back
i'm back and tasha is done with it all
i'm done i don't want to do it anymore
and oh my gosh one of those two episodes
involves the men
tell all it's mental all like you have
never seen before with the return of
joseph i'm not going to apologize oh and
they are
truly trying to scare us now because the
comedic button at the end of the episode
is
ed in a silence of the lamb's ask face
mask
i do a little skin care routines here
and there actually it's nothing it's
just get botox every three months
and speaking of it's time for me to
reveal my two truths and a lie
and the truth is i'm allergic to face
masks yes i am my eyes swell up
the other truth is i was on a volleyball
team yes once in middle school i was on
the c
a b c level and i missed a ball that
lost us the state championship
the lie is i have three siblings i only
have two
i'm the oldest of three what are you
guys where do you fall in your sibling
ranking order and how do you feel about
how that affects you as you grow up
nature versus nurture do you think that
you're a leader and that you take care
of people if you're the oldest
do you think that you're the most
irresponsible if you're the youngest do
you think that you fall into the
retreat into the wayside if you're in
the middle let me know in the comments
below
cake but i love you all so much
thank you thank you thank you as always
for watching and if you want to connect
with me more
i am available on instagram tick tock
and twitter at laurenzema you can also
find me on
cameo if you want to go to their website
you can get a personal message
from me i love you i can't wait to talk
to you about
the men tell all and the other episode
next week monday and tuesday night
two bachelorette episodes we will be
recapping both
in one roses and rose episode available
on wednesday as
usual love you thank you cake
bye hey guys
it's me just had to do a quick vlog
cause i'm alone in my car
eating a cake did you know they make
personal
cake personal size they didn't have any
chocolate but i just
bought this i really needed the cake
oh my gosh real good anyway polarizing
question but
do you guys miss claire and dale i love
jason but claire and neal are fun to
watch i'll tell ya
let me know in the comments below okay
bye